varios tarros de pintura unos pinceles y
un fular para cubrir su cara Esto es lo
único que necesita Carlos satoche para
dar rienda suelta a su imaginación este
artista urbano de origen peruano pinta
exclusivamente en incógnito
hace años decidí meter mi entidad oculta
en una voluntad de querer que la gente
te identifique más con tus obras que con
tu cara no desde hace más de 10 años
Carlos pinta murales callejeros en
países como Marruecos china Perú y
Vietnam esta mañana su Lienzo es esta
fachada de este edificio abandonado en
el sur de Roma ese diálogo que hay entre
la obra y
el marco arquitectónico Pues es lo que
lo hace un arte única digamos no pintar
en la calle es sin filtros es mucho más
directo la escrita Es un arte que se
expande por sí sola no es un organismo
vivo una forma de expresión cada vez más
visible en Roma que interesar al mundo
del turismo estos visitantes participan
a un toura típico en un barrio de la
periferia transformado en museo a cielo
abierto
Esta obra representa a los bombardeos en
Roma de 1943 durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial pero también Las Guerras en el
mundo que desafortunadamente siguen
ocurriendo hoy en día
es muy importante porque en general uno
viene a Roma y ve siempre las mismas
cosas Iglesias El Vaticano y arte
tradicional Y entonces es excelente
poder descubrir esto que es tan
diferente e inusual
obras que denuncian la pobreza la
violencia de género o Inclusive la
contaminación ambiental como esta
gigantesca imagen de una garza sobre un
barril de petróleo se trata del mural
ecológico más grande de Europa
para este mural se usaron pinturas
fotocatalíticas es decir que reaccionan
al contacto con la luz atacan las
partículas de polución y las disuelven
este mural absorbe la polución genera da
por 80 carros al día
actualmente unos 330 murales de interés
artístico decoran la ciudad de Roma